I can now manipulate my audience I can
now make videos without any substance I
can now make the same videos over and
over and still stay relevant some hi
have dyed my hair
[Music]
little teenage girls will bow before me
they will buy all my merchants they will
click like on all my videos some say I
am the new tenement goat of the internet
[Music]
let's just let's just take out all the
comparisons so you can just fight a
shock and shut up and move on
Jack Frost Danny Phantom Dante from
Dante's Inferno albino kazoo kid and
people are already in outrage why sad
face sad face sad face sad face sad face
and they said they said they said they
said they said they said they said they
said they said they said why your hair
is awful Oh vomiting stop change it back
what made you think that dyeing your
hair white was a good idea
have you heard of use I can literally
make a 10-minute video with no substance
about my hair a thing that literally
anyone else on the [ __ ] planet will
not care about pee deep eyes white hair
has the internet shook but why did he do
it why did he do
[Music]
there are some seriously unanswered
questions RN I mean it's practically
been covered by every news media outlet
in the world now speaking in pewdiepie
he tweeted out today saying just thought
I look really cute in this picture I
will probably delete later showing here
that now he dyed his hair white and he's
putting makeup on so I guess PewDiePie
has a whole new look now that [ __ ] did
you say scarce has a whole new look now
are you trying to make fun of my hair
scarce you piece a [ __ ] [ __ ] you're
mocking me for my physical appearance so
I just pity if I has a whole new look
how could you do that I am disappointed
in you scares I thought you were better
than it
[Music]
let's see what you guys thought about my
haircut cuz your opinions matter more to
me than anyone elses is My Chemical
Romance back together now I mean getting
throw back feels from your hair man oh
god damn it I forgot about Gerard
I'm a little scared how [ __ ] I am
with makeup Smasher Pass make your pick
is he is he turning into a massive
[ __ ] listen I will do anything
anything to get out of this YouTube
hellhole okay hey pills you have to
drink the bleach not put it in your hair
[ __ ] now I'm old paranoid about my hair
and [ __ ] stop oh oh [ __ ] I forgot hey
how's the gum brush my name is Peter
pack and welcome to
[Music]
I want it actually you know all jokes
aside I wanted to make an update video
today it's been a while I know I've been
bitching and complaining a lot lately
and I want to say I am sorry I wanted
this video to be positive so let's talk
about some positive things
[Music]
it's kind of hard as it
[Music]
I can't oh my god oh yeah I got an
update on the whole moderator things I
said I would add you guys as moderators
well turns out I can I tried three times
now I add people as moderators whenever
i refresh the page they're all gone but
that's really good that that feature is
there it's not really pasta to visit oh
of course I know hey super has the
Valentine's Day update it's actually
really cool I know a lot of you like no
one plays the game anymore yet really
really funny there's a lot of people
playing the game myself included and in
fact anyone who is cool like me is
playing the game look how I'm playing
right now
[Music]
this event is only lasting 12 days so if
you want to get like the unique items
you can only get it during these days so
if you have the game install
check it out and download there's also a
new feature called networks where you
basically can join each other's networks
it's pretty cool you can join my network
called please kill me
honestly I am blown away by the
creativity of people playing the game
because the net the online feature is
working really well now and I think when
it the game was new there was too many
people playing it and he just didn't
work properly but seeing how well people
implement the themes it's just it's so
cool to see people being creative in so
this this thing was PewDiePie this is
the winner so cool this is a second this
is the third oh yeah I ranked 232 in my
own [ __ ] game about myself
Bravo me good job Felix a lot of you
guys have also been asking about sleepy
is he alive
I wouldn't just kill sleepy ok like I'm
not a [ __ ] psychopath there we go I'm
nervous oh no oh no oh wait anyway I'll
show you look he's fine say something
sleepy tell them you're fine just don't
[ __ ] on me right now
you look like Draco Malfoy caught aids
sleepy you do not have to comment about
my hair it's a compliment
ok fine you want to go back don't you
how about you give me a kiss first no
please
the AIDS thank you see he didn't even
take [ __ ] oh [ __ ] I forgot about the
most important up thing we're in the
office we are in the old penguin penguin
club penguin office and last video I did
you guys basically crashed the servers
of the game so I'm proud of you
basically our job was to to stop penguin
from dying and we crashed a service
that's that's pretty good I love this
new office it's
coming together really nicely downstairs
we're literally shooting a show called
scare PewDiePie game over
not sure if I'm allowed to say that but
it's really cool they were they
literally built a set in like just a few
days and we can use it afterwards so I'm
so proud I'm so I I really love doing
bigger shows and stuff like that the
problem is I don't have time for it it
always involves me like going to LA or
something like that and the fact that I
can literally just go downstairs to
shoot a show it's so [ __ ] cool to me
I am so thrilled about this office and
I'd really really really don't want to
get thrown out
oh yeah it's almost like a dream come
true to just have everything here I love
this space more youtubers coming in PJ's
been using it a lot Mars has been using
it and it's just got a good vibe in it I
really enjoy it so there's a lot of
stuff going on here is the set it's
cinnamon toast can everyone if anyone
asked there that was not me
okay so stepping up the game in 2017
this is not a vlogging camera it's
[ __ ] awkward as hell the whole we
have this chalk pillar that everyone's
been drawing all kinds of [ __ ] on PG
especially in his friends I especially
appreciate I know a lot of people are
gonna look at this and be like oh pretty
pie has an office now he's treating
YouTube as a job I always used to think
that it would I had so much advantage
because like I could just record at home
and I can just do everything at home but
I find that it's so much better to
separate your home and my job I guess
YouTube is my job there you go everyone
I waste less time if I go somewhere to
record my videos and when I'm home I can
just relax and
everything off which is really hard as a
youtuber so pro tip if your youtuber and
you can afford getting an office get an
office anyway let's go back Jesus Christ
Ainsley it's [ __ ] terrifying oh my
god so that's you know actually
something positive hey I did it they
didn't even have to force it out okay
well I need to force out some some
positivity as well so it feels really
good to just sit down and not having to
get ready and talk to you guys I just
want to apologize for the way I look and
the way I sound you guys are my best
friends
I always want to keep it real with you
guys but honestly it feels really really
good just to not have to get all ready
and like sit down and talk to you guys
mom no for real
thank you for all the support as always
I feel like people are finally getting
over these [ __ ] comments would like
oh wait I wish I wish he just played a
game and and all these [ __ ] like I
prefer pudy pie in 1984 I've seen people
making these jokes instead and that's
it's really nice that people are finally
getting over it and I can just kind of
do what I want and people appreciating
me doing what I want as well I know I
focus a lot of negative that doesn't
mean I don't see the positive and I
apologize about if I'm always after like
the dumb [ __ ] people saying only giving
them attention because there's a lot of
you there are genuinely nice people and
you deserve some love too so hey if you
ever left me a nice comment I want you
right now to take your hand and place it
place it behind your back and pat
yourself give yourself a pat and imagine
that it's my hand don't do don't get all
weird and sexual it's just it's just a
nice little gesture so that we can do
this together thing okay that's enough
thank you
that being said that's all I had to say